well where would you like to start this
first little five minute segment uh is
is just kind of a Prelude to what's
coming up what do you want to cover here
today
just God runs the world and Jesus is the
way and the life and it's time to put
Jesus first and the way that we run our
businesses the way we the way we run our
families our businesses and the way we
run our country
your radio listeners run over 400 radio
stations they can't see you right now
you're you're this is a new look for you
oh no I've been wearing a mask for a
while
oh yeah so this is an archetypal example
that the mask is off by putting the mask
on
people could take it how they how they
want to take it
[Applause]
and his final Messengers Muhammad peace
be upon him this is our religion Islam
Islam this is the beach
when I was ready to talk about it I
would only talk to yes and I was
explaining how much respect I have for
the faith of Islam
foreign
ladies and gentlemen Imam costume Khan
here on the dean show assalamu alaikum
well
I have a lot of mean so how far is he
from you he said he's from uh Austin
Texas Austin is a is several is several
hours from Houston okay about maybe four
hours something like that so uh before
we get into uh Kanye how you been how's
everything with you pretty good
alhamdulillah treats me far better than
I deserve to be treated so for that I've
praised him 24 7. alhamdulillah that's
beautiful uh that we've been given that
opportunity to do that and I was
thinking just listening to Kanye if he
would if he just took uh and replaced
Jesus and just put God
in place of Jesus when he's talking
about the more I'm obedient to God the
more I'm obedient to the Creator yes
there'll be a shift there but it'd be
the right shift it's just an adjustment
because he's talking about you know uh
his love for Jesus it seems like more
than his love for the Creator uh
absolutely you know I I respect I have a
an innate respect for all people who are
sincerely religious
um and I'm very I'm hesitant to
criticize
um in a negative way those who have
um a
um warped uh understanding of who God is
in the presence of God
um I really do believe
and if I can put the best construction
on what I heard from Kanye West I really
do believe that he's uh basically just
been misinformed
because he is under the impression
that Jesus peace be upon him has all the
power he is under the impression that
Jesus speaks to be upon Him is one who
is supposed to be the object of our
worship and that's the impression that
he has so
um but what whatever is taken if he has
a a a a Pious demeanor and a Pious and
righteous way of life
then obviously the only thing missing is
him to have a correct understanding of
the importance of the presence of God
and so he's been misinformed and I would
really love the opportunity to properly
inform him or to uh expose him to
someone who can because uh it's not so
much that I'm impressed with his with
his celebrity status that doesn't
impress me
um nor am I moved by his decision to
keep his face covered that doesn't move
me one way or the other but the words
that he utters people listen to because
of his celebrity you know and there are
some people who refuse to study that
some people just don't study
um who who are of the same opinion that
he is is that someone who is created by
God should be the object of worship you
know and so that's that's something that
I think that needs to be corrected and I
do believe that the only reason
he hasn't accepted Islam is simply
because he just doesn't understand it
that's just got to be the only reason
because anybody who truly takes the time
to understand and internalize the true
Message of Islam will accept it so
that's why I don't criticize people who
haven't accepted because they just don't
understand just like you at one point
you didn't understand you were a
Christian right absolutely I mean even
when I thought that I had the true Islam
I didn't truly understand then you went
to the nation I went the Nation of Islam
I thought that was the pure Islam and
and there again that's another reason
why I don't even criticize those who are
of that mindset because I just don't
understand at some point I didn't
understand and so I don't think that I
could be it would be productive for me
to merely just spend time criticizing
um Kanye West or anybody else of that of
that similar mindset and just spend time
talking about how wrong he is what I
would like to do is pray for and focus
on an opportunity to uh to have to help
him truly understand what Islam is about
and that actually so because if he
understands it he will realize as as
though many others should the Islam
actually is part of our nature it's in
the nature of every human being when
we're born every person that's born on
the face of this Earth has a Birthright
to the understanding of the Oneness of
almighty God that pure monotheism you
are exposed to and inshallah God will we
can get Kanye West right now exposed to
it even Alex Jones who's hosting him on
this show you've heard of Alex he's also
over there in uh Texas so we got a Texan
over here former Christian with the
nation and now has submitted his will to
the creator of heavens and earth in
Islam that's what Islam means to submit
your will like in the Lord's Prayer
isn't it or a Father who art in heaven
Hallowed be thy name thy will be done
and it's amazing too that even even in
the I used to love singing that song uh
when I was a Christian but even if if
they think about it see some people just
don't stop and think because the most
popular prayer in the Christian
um faith is The Lord's Prayer
and when Jesus peace be upon Him taught
that Lord's Prayer to his disciples his
sahaba for lack of a better term that if
you notice that prayer begins in the
plural and it's non-possessive because
he he didn't he didn't say My Father who
art he said our father yes which means
that everyone who was created by God and
everyone was is spiritually his children
we belong to him you know so he never
claimed exclusive rights to God you know
of for himself he said Our Father who
art in heaven Hallowed be thy name and
then the further in the Bible uh the
part of the Bible that didn't get
contaminated by King James because he
contaminated a good part of it
then then he also uh acknowledged Jesus
peace be upon him he also acknowledged
that those people who promote peace are
actually God's children because in the
Beatitudes he said blessed are the
peacemakers for they shall be called the
children of God so that's him speaking
that's not my words you know so if they
think about if he would think about what
he's actually saying if he thinks about
what he actually holds dear to him which
is words from the Bible which he calls
his book then if you stop and think
about it for a minute he'll realize that
he's given the credit and the in the
attention and the in the the loyalty to
the wrong entity he's given it to a
human being that was created by by the
God he should be worshiping it's just
that simple what would you tell Kanye
right now if he's here he's watching
he's listening or if you had a chance to
hook up with him in Texas or Alex Jones
for that matter and now we're talking
about this key figure Jesus what would
you tell him about your relationship
with Jesus now as a Muslim them
first thing I would do is what I've done
in the past because many Christian
preachers have come to talk to me
some of them have even accepted Islam
because they they asked me a rhetorical
question why don't you believe in Jesus
and I say well I love Jesus peace be
upon him so much that in by religion
it's considered sacrilegious to keep
mentioning his name without praying for
him I have to pray for him just to
mention this even though the name that I
use is incorrect because his name wasn't
Jesus it's nowhere that's not it's not
even Aramaic it's not that wasn't even
the language he spoke you know he never
heard the word but but since I know the
that's what we're referring to is the
Christ then I have to pray for him I
have to say Jesus peace be upon him or
Christ be upon him and as a matter of
fact I would argue
if I want to admit that when I was
practicing Christianity Eddie that I was
more in love with the name than I was in
love with the person and if you look at
it now if I was to call myself Yeshua
and say I'm changing my name to Joshua
nobody will complain if I was a chain
might change my name to Jesus which is
Spanish no one will complain if I change
my name to Esau which is Arabic no one
will complain but if I say I want to
change my name to Jesus many Christians
would be in the Uproar they said you
can't call yourself Jesus that's the
lord's name because they're in love with
the name you know but he'll talk about
the same person however that the pure
example of Jesus peace be upon Him
excuse me
is one that me as a Muslim I as a Muslim
hold dear that's a it's a beautiful
example even though he wasn't the final
Prophet but he was a major prophet a
whole deer because there's things that
he refused to do that I also refused to
do there's no record where Jesus speaks
to be upon Him took in intoxicants now
there's there's scriptures in the Bible
say you turn the water to wine but it
wasn't it was not intoxicating wine so
he did not drink intoxicants Jesus peace
be upon him did not partake in a tobacco
he didn't smoke Beast be upon him he
didn't use drugs peace be upon him he
was very careful about how he dressed he
didn't wear revealing clothes and even
this even the record of how his mother
dressed is how the Muslim women
dressed today loose-fitting clothing
very very modest and he just like that I
try to do invite people to God that's my
mission and that was his mission and so
I so I try to follow it for the example
even though he's not the major focal
point of my religion of course the major
focal point in my religion is Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him but also
I don't deny the beautiful example that
this Mighty prophet of God Jesus peace
be upon him or Isa even barium he said
the son of Mary projected to the world
so I don't understand
uh how I even was even when I looked
back on how I was even so attractive or
so addicted to one but one human being
but when I realized that I didn't
understand I hadn't internalized the
fact that the god that created every
human being and everything else that
exists ex this God was in place who
developed an enriching the entire
universe
um generations and generations before
Jesus speaks to be upon him and all the
prophets even preceded him uh when you
mentioned Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessed to be upon him who's a brother
to Jesus who's a brother to all the
preceding Messengers Abraham Noah Moses
they all brought the same message that
pure monotheism to tawheed it has me
thinking about a Hadith is saying an
authentic saying from Prophet Muhammad
where he's describing a beautiful built
house brick house mansion and people are
going around it and they're just one
brick missing there and this thing is
just so beautiful but there's just one
brick missing he says I am that brick
I'm the Seal of the prophets I'm the
final messenger you're sent to mankind
this is all it is it's not that Muslims
worship Muhammad but they are following
his way of the teachings of prophet
Muhammad just like Jesus at his time
calling his people to worship God
Muhammad being the last and final
messenger is he a messenger also for
Kanye West and Alex Jones he's a
messenger for everyone for everyone you
know he's a message for everyone and and
the thing about it is I don't know why
so many people
um uh who are who call themselves
Christians they deny parts of their own
book you know I don't understand it you
know I don't criticize them for it
that's the that's the that's the boat
they want to float but I don't criticize
them for because you Jesus speaks be
upon him told them in part of the Bible
that was not contaminated by King James
in Matthew 5 17 he said think not that I
came to destroy the law or the prophets
but I came to fulfill and so that should
be a clear message what's wrong with
that I mean where is it we're we're the
where is the message being missed you
know and I don't understand that's the
part that I I don't get I don't
understand why it's so difficult to
understand that Jesus peace be upon Him
brought a message of of monotheism he
didn't direct anybody to to worship him
or his mother Trinity the Trinity none
of that and matter of fact as a Muslim I
have to believe that is or Jesus the son
of Mary peace be upon Him is coming back
but he's not coming back to sing in a
choir he's not coming back to to put up
a Christmas tree he's coming back to ask
some serious questions that the people
are going to have to answer who was it
who told you to worship me and my mother
instead of God because it wasn't me
who told you to do where'd you get that
from that's the question he's going to
be asking and they're going to have to
answer that question you know if you ask
them now the the I used to ask I asked
that question during during the latter
part of my Christian Life and I was told
don't don't don't question the Bible
don't question okay okay I'll be quiet
but that's a serious question that needs
to be answered very serious and do you
think that Alex Jones you've heard of
Alex Jones right he's from Texas there a
little bit yeah there's a lot of
controversy around him but we have an
Islam love for everybody for mankind and
we alsoever sharing this message do you
think that Alex Jones now he had an
interview with the captain no the uh the
main guy Louis Farrakhan he had him on
his show Alex has a show and he had
Louis Farrakhan on the show so now he's
probably thinking this is Islam because
he's having the person that now is
representing the nation on his show so
how do you think it would go if he had
you on the program versus having Louis
Farrakhan on the program at that time
and probably getting mixed messages
mixed signals
well uh it's hard to be dogmatic and I
can only assume yeah
um first of all I would assume that
because you were a captain in the nation
right no I was a minister you're a
minister yes I didn't I didn't go all
the way straight through the ranks step
by step so you're a minister in the
nation after after become after uh
leaving Christianity you became a
minister so go ahead yes so my point is
I'm not a hundred percent convinced that
that host that that had invited Minister
farcon on this show I'm not 100
convinced that he uh thinks it does pure
Sloan I'm not convinced that he did that
you know because people who are in the
media whether journalists writers or
whatever
um anchor people they Thrive off of
sensationalism yes you know and so I'm
not convinced you know I don't I don't
have any um public criticism for
Minister Farrakhan that's the road that
I travel to get where I am now you know
and I'm taught by the Quran to respect
the womb that bore me so that's the room
that bore me that's the that's the road
that Almighty Allah
um chose for me to travel to get where I
am now that was his choice not mine and
so that's the road I travel but I'm not
on that road anymore you know so if I
was to be invited to be on that same
show I would just simply clarify I
wouldn't even have to criticize what
everyone else believes I would clarify
what it is that I believe I will clarify
what I understand I'll clarify my
perception and my understanding of the
purity of Islam and and let the chips
fall where they may because Islam
Islam confirms itself Allah says in the
Quran that that the truth knocks out
falsehood's brains you know so I it's
not Islam is so pure and so and so
sensible that it's not necessary for me
to spend any time criticizing others if
I just tell what the truth is now I can
I can talk about what I used to believe
you know and if people want to perceive
that as being criticized as being
critical then that's the that's the boat
they want to float and that's fine you
know but but I used to believe the
things that I'm hearing now I actually
brother Eddie I have
um uh an edge
over uh the Christians because I know
more about Christianity than they know
about Islam you know so that's the edge
it's nothing to boast about it's just
that I can understand
um where they're coming from you know
when they say that but but my but but
seeing but realizing after practicing
Islam for almost for about 50 years
realizing how how sensible it is
to to see that there can only possibly
be just one God and that everything else
in creation was actually created by him
and so nothing else could be worthy of
worship except the one who created
everything and that's basic common sense
that's that's basic Common Sense 101.
yeah very uh common sense but it's uh
shame common sense is not common
practice and you mentioned earlier about
alcohol
and many of these vices that are people
dealing with uh nicotine smoking and
drugs and everything and Alex Jones uh
he's recently came out also talking
about uh the effect that the alcoholism
affecting his life for the for the
negative but Islam you know solves all
those problems it has your clear path
because it's kind of ambiguous in the
Bible you know it's no it's a lot of
times a lot of things are clear but
people have all these different opinions
so it's like you know people there's not
a clear road map as defined in Islam
it's there are certain things that are
just clear alcohol is forbidden gambling
is forbidden there's no way uh if or
what about it but on the other side over
here it's like people are just like make
up things as you go did you notice that
when you're back because people have a
tendency to to look for some way to
justify their own weakness you know they
want to justify their own weakness by
claiming that well and this is this is
the phrase they use that doesn't really
connect with me they said they say Jesus
died to save the world from sin well I'm
trying to figure out which sin did he
die to save the world from because if he
died to save the world from sin and
people are still sit still sinning you
know then which one which one did he
actually die from it doesn't make sense
to me you know because
if Jesus peace be upon him
um if he since he had had a beautiful
example of piety and righteousness and
that was and that's what he projected
then the things that he did that to help
to to promote the the Oneness of
almighty God and the worship in the
direction to that God the things that he
did or seems seems to be uh uh
misconstrued by those who claim to
follow him and this and this and they're
really confusing their own selves that's
the way that I see it yeah a lot of
people uh like that Kanye West so I
don't listen to I I mean obviously we
don't promote Kanye West but we're
trying to out of love trying to you see
a person falling apart right in front of
you and you want to give them the
antidote and the solution to all their
problems and help them like you said
people don't know they don't understand
so we're trying to deliver this message
to Kanye West inshallah God willing he
gets this and even Alex Jones because
the solution to their problems and the
messages for everybody Islam submission
to the Creator not the creation so this
uh thing that he exposes a lot of times
Kanye is the corruption which is
self-evident in Hollywood and in the
industry there you know all of the the
corruption that's in there so he it's
refreshing for a lot of people to see
someone who's in that industry speaking
against the industry
but they're still an industry right yeah
yeah well that's kind of that's kind of
like what Malcolm said you know the
chicken's coming home to roost you know
because basically
um when it when it comes home to bite
you and you realize that you don't even
see your own contradiction you know
people contradict themselves sadly uh
even in Islam they're they're Muslim to
have a tendency to contradict themselves
you know but right now we can see a very
very clear contradictions if someone
says I'm a Christian and I asked the
Christian what's the definition of
Christianity and it says to be
christ-like well then I asked the
question well then ask yourself what was
Christ like you know um the only reason
why I even spend the time to even
mention people like Alex Jones and Kanye
West and even some others uh Snoop Dogg
and all the other is because they're in
the news you know and and since they're
in the news and people have a tendency
to be attracted to what's in the media
and be moved and and by the media and
the media is nothing but a demagogue
then then I I'll bring up things and uh
to make them think about what they're
spending their time with yeah you know
so in the me so the media wants to
promote something because the media said
I was a journalist I wrote for several
newspapers and I and I used to thrive on
sensationalism if something wasn't
wasn't Sensational you know if it wasn't
negative enough you know then I I wasn't
attracted to it and that's what the
media does you know so we can we can
look at what is happening in the in this
in the world today and we notice that um
there is
um Wars going on all around the world
there is people starving and hungry
there's people that are billionaires
that if they were to to practice the uh
the The Institute the the uh the
practice of just zakat in Islam if the
institution of zakat was practiced
worldwide there would be no hunger yes
there will be no starving no starvation
no nothing because the billionaires
would have to give 2.5 percent of their
of what's left over after they pay their
expenses and that would take care of
everybody but that's too much like right
you know so Islam is too much like right
for some people you know and they and
and so they're they're they're they're
addicted to and attracted to something
that seems tempting to them and and
something that will give them the
license for lack of a better term to to
continue to do the things that they're
weak for and that's what Islam see
islamophobia I would argue
that islamophobia is not limited to
people who haven't accepted Islam
because phobia means to be afraid of
something there are people who are
afraid of their own religion there's
people who are afraid to leave and step
away from things that they're addicted
to there's people that just can't handle
the truth about themselves and so they
look for something that would allow them
the flexibility and the latitude to to
continue
um to practice the things that are wrong
that they're just addicted to and they
want something that's going to justify
their weakness and so if Islam doesn't
justify the weakness I have a friend
that I grew up with uh in in in the
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania area and I asked
them okay and he said I love your
message of Islam matter of fact he
watched one of my Dean show episodes uh
over and over again he almost memorized
it the one where I was on the show with
you we talked about Snoop Dogg uh
joining the nation
he said he said if you if I if you gave
that message while we was growing up
everybody in our hometown would have
been Muslim I said what's stopping you
now buddy yeah you know what's stopping
you now from accepting Islam I said is
there anything about Islam you disagree
with he said no
I said well is there anything about
Islam you don't understand he said no he
said then tell me why haven't you
accepted Islam I was trying to open the
door for for you know the dollar and he
said to be honest with you I don't
believe I have the discipline to do what
being a Muslim requires and I respected
that now now these people to get on to
try to land blast Islam or try to shoot
it down or try to say we're all
terrorists and we're violent and all of
that stuff you know just be honest you
know they say that I love you you don't
love Jesus peace be upon him if you
really love Jesus peace be upon him you
would live your life the way that he
lived his life you know if you really
loved him if you loved him you would
pray for him like I do every time his
name is mentioned if you loved him you
were more modest clothes if you loved
him you would eat the same diet that he
ate if you love him so much in in
Judaism
um the the the the the Orthodox Jews
they pray in the language that Musa
peace be upon Him prayed in right in
Islam the Muslims pray in the language
that Muhammad prayed in peace be upon
him right but Christianity Issa had been
married anymore Jesus speaks be upon him
he spoke Aramaic and he prayed in
Aramaic I haven't met there might be
somewhere on the planet Earth I haven't
met one Christian that prays in Aramaic
you know if that's if that's the focal
point but never mind the language how
about living the life that this person
who you say is so important to you like
he lived
you know why why why what's your problem
why do you continue to eat pork you know
what that's an old Mosaic law that Jesus
did away with that's not true I just
quoted Matthew 5 17. he said he didn't
do away with the law do what he did
my family my wife and my my
granddaughter that I'm raising they
dress exactly the way the pictures of
Miriam uh the mother of Jesus peace be
upon her and him dressed you know and
and so we have to real be honest with
ourselves I would challenge our
challenge not only Kanye West but other
people they don't have to be celebrities
I would challenge anyone if you say you
believe in someone if you say you you
love someone if you say that you respect
someone if you say you honor someone you
know and if you if you say all of that
from your mouth then why don't you live
the way that person lived at least do
that if you want to be wrong about
whether or not he should be worshiped be
wrong about that but at least be right
about something that's the way I see it
now maybe I'm wrong I don't know but I'm
waiting for somebody to correct me
that's deep I like what you said you
asked him so what don't you like about
Islam and he was honest because any
sincere person that looks into Islam I
mean the message is really
straightforward loosen and clear you
know all of the different things is the
moral code it just goes to fit through
the nature it makes sense for some
anyone who wants to get close to God
it's just really common sense a lot of
the things are there but even if this
person is not so disciplined they can
still accept Islam and get discipline it
takes some effort and time like anything
but if you value something if you value
your life and you want to have a better
life you want to become closer to your
creator do you love your desires more
you love your creators so you're going
to go ahead Islam doesn't you know have
you just become perfect overnight it
helps you to become a better human being
by implementing the injunctions and
everything there that's there to help
you to grow but a lot of people uh they
maybe have that misconception that's an
excellent point
that's an excellent point that you
brought up and that is that
um you if you really uh if you really
believe that there's nothing in the
religion that you disagree with you know
and and and this is what I tell people
we give many many people shahada many
people come to our Masjid in Houston
Texas and they accept Islam and we tell
them you're there's only one thing that
you're obligated to change right away
and that is your perception or your
respect for the presence of God in your
life because once you once you once you
change that perception and understand
that he is most important then all your
decisions are going to fall in place
because everything that you do you'll be
doing because you want to please him so
maybe you have troubles quitting smoking
you might maybe you have trouble
drinking maybe you have trouble even
fornicating whatever you do whatever you
have trouble doing if you if you just
think for a minute that you have to
please this Mighty God then all of these
things that you're that you're doing
that that God forbids you'll start
changing them on your own because you
want to please this God so it's not
necessary for me to micromanage your
life and nitpick your life and tell you
you got to quit this you kind of quit
that you can't do this you can't eat
that it's not necessary for me to do all
of that all I need to do is make sure
you understand it once you say there's
no God but Allah Muhammad is the
messenger of God once you say that then
you are then your obligation falls on
you to internalize that and re and make
all your decisions to reflect your
belief in the fact that this God sees
you he's with you he's recording and
seeing everything that you say and do
and you must please him so then you just
ask yourself is what I'm going to eat
pleasing to this God is what I'm going
to wear pleasing to this God is what I'm
gonna say to people is what I'm going to
watch on TV is it all going to be
pleasing to go you ask yourself that
simple honest question that's why I
respect my friend down in Pittsburgh you
know I'm still I'm still trying to
encourage him to accept Islam before he
he dies the same age that I am but I
respect his honest answer he didn't try
to make excuses he said well I don't
believe I have the discipline I said
well you can't get it right away only
thing that you have to discipline
yourself to do is make up your mind that
this is the god that you want to try to
please with whatever you do yeah and uh
it's amazing just these signs are it's
like when people wake up to this reality
and they just you know when their heart
is open their mind is open they were
sincere like yourself obviously you're
seeking to know the truth as a Christian
and you didn't find it there in the
Trinity or all these misconceptions
about Jesus it didn't make sense the
contradictions you saw through it went
to the nation that didn't that didn't
add up then you came to the pure
monotheism of Islam the actual real
Islam according to the Quran the
verbatim word of God and the Sunnah the
way of the last and final Master is sent
to Mankind and now you're a Muslim one
who submitted his or her will and
talking to people like if you talk to
Kanye Alex Jones any any other people
the average John Joe whoever's out there
and someone who brings up Jesus and they
just compare like you mentioned some
things like Jesus peace be upon him we
pray like him real Common Sense this is
just basic knowledge for everyone so we
pray like Jesus putting your face on the
ground that's how Muslims pray you
mentioned his mother right dear wife you
know the Muslim women imitate Mary the
mother of Jesus they pray to the god of
Jesus they don't eat pork like Jesus
they were circumcised like Jesus they
greet like Jesus
peace be with you and the list goes on
yes absolutely I mean that's the if
those are not enough Signs by themselves
without even getting into the the
miracle of the Quran the the
authenticity of the Quran the all of the
proofs and evidences that the Quran has
it's a living miracle today just these
small little samples signed these things
that we just threw out there it's like
wow but you gotta be like your mind
heart got to be open no and yes but also
um the the ball is in the court of the
most systems who understand this
religion what I mean by that is we have
a responsibility and a duty to give
dawah you know that's our responsibility
and and and and Allah in the Quran he
addresses Humanity uh as the children of
Adam he said oh by the Adam yabbani Adam
the children of Adam who is he talking
to he's not just talking to Muslims he
is talking to everyone on planet Earth
who is a descendant of Adam and Eve
right so that makes everyone brothers
and sisters they may not be brothers and
sisters in the faith but but nonetheless
in the eyes of Allah we're brothers and
sisters now we now that means that we
have an obligation to them to give them
dawah to make them understand right okay
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings of
Allah be upon him he said
not one of you is a Believer with your
love for your brother what you love for
your own self so the the so the
responsibility ability and the weight is
on the shoulders of the Muslims do we
love our brothers our brothers our
brothers in humanity what do you love
for yourself ask yourself that question
do we love Islam do I love Islam for
myself am I happy to be Muslim am I
happy to be one who is striving to get
to Paradise excuse me am I am I am I
happy to be fasting in Ramadan happy to
approach the five daily prayers happy to
go to Mecca is this is this make me
happy that means that if this what I
want for myself I should want that for
my brothers and sisters and that means
that I have an obligation to give them
that one I have opportunity uh
obligation to look for opportunities to
give dawah one of one of my mentors Imam
siraj rahaj he he made a very prophetic
statement I'm not saying he's a prophet
don't get me on Facebook talking about I
said he made a prophetic statement he
said never miss a dollar moment you know
so that's our that's our job that's our
responsibility that's our duty Allah
says
oh you really fulfill all of your
obligations so that's Our obligation to
give dawah now that means we have to
create opportunities or develop I should
say opportunities to give dawah and and
dawah and the definition of that what
one might say is an educational
invitation that's and that's an
invitation that means that that we
should always look for opportunities or
develop opportunities to give dawah to
make people understand the beauty of
Islam not just to argue not to be
combative not to try to kill somebody
how wrong they are but but give them a
clear understanding of This Dean that is
our duty that is Our obligation and
that's why every opportunity that we
have to to to present Islam in the
communities All Over America and even
some part in many places outside of
America many many churches are closing
down and they're becoming massages
and one beautiful example just recently
happened down in Florida
there is a there is a mega uh of area it
was a mega church and now it has
opportunity to become a Dean Center this
is your brother Hamza Andreas and I want
every single one of you to support Eddie
from the dean show financially and
otherwise but in what way
I want you to support his new project
the dean center it's going to be a
transformative experience in the center
why because it's going to be a Masjid
it's going to be a place of worship it's
also going to have Fitness facilities
and it's also going to be a dollar
Center to call people back to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala Muslims and
non-muslims and we trust Eddie
completely I for one would take a
thousand bullets for Eddie he has a
vision he has more than 15 years of
experience in the dawah he's had a huge
success with the dean show and he had
the support of many Duart and preachers
and Scholars from all around the world
it's going to be an amazing project for
everybody go to the dean center.org
donate now
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
a major Dean center now what is this
going to do for Humanity this is not
only an opportunity it's a sign Allah
says surely this or sign for those who
reflect it's a beautiful sign it's a
great opportunity for for the Muslims to
show how important and demonstrate how
important it is to take take that word
to another level this is the New
Millennium so we should we should be
looking for opportunities to let the
world see put it on a on a on a huge
stage not to be stuck in some little
corner in the back woods in the suburbs
somewhere where nobody could hear it you
know but but on the world stage in a
beautiful uh complex a major facility a
multi-purpose facility like that
facility that we're putting together
down in Florida the deed Center that's a
major major responsibility and a duty
for all the Muslims to do whatever we
can to get that open and and and it will
become an example and to catapult the
the rest of the world and to send maybe
we need to do this too so instead of
seeing a church on every corner this
should be a a Masjid or a Darwin Center
in in every place that we could possibly
put it not to try to to prosely
everybody but just just to educate
everybody this is an educational
invitation for if uh to let the people
see the beauty of Islam and action is
part of their nature because Muslim
means one who has the nature to the
submit to the will of the one God
those who call themselves Muslim are
those who submit to that nature say okay
this is what I'm supposed to do I'm
supposed to submit this one God and I
should call everybody else to submit to
this one God beautiful beautiful
alhamdulillah it was always uh nice
having you on a program I really thank
you for sharing that with us
and giving that beautiful advice
it's my pleasure Eddie it's upon a lot
my pleasure and it is and as we conclude
in the spirit of assalamu alaikum if you
notice that's plural that means I'm
obligated to want the peace from God to
be extended upon you and everyone who's
connected to you even those I can't see
there's people who we don't come in
contact with people we will never see
that will be impacted by the opening of
the dean Center once week once we get it
done I emphasize week once we get it
done people need to understand what with
the impact on the world and how much
better off this world will be if we have
more of those Insurance absolutely so on
my project and you heard the share that
we're going to try to make this a
reality opening up the first mega dollar
Center in the United States of America
here to extend that education or
invitation because if you care you share
and we're sharing so go ahead and make
sure you tune in here and support the
dean Center we'll see you next time
thank you shake always as always and
thank you guys for tuning in subscribing
if you haven't already and make sure you
visit the dean show to get your free
copy of the Quran if you want to really
know what these Muslims are talking
about and is there room for you
absolutely there is if you believe that
there's only one God worthy of worship
you don't want to worship your desires
the creation a man a monkey a stick a
stone a bone you want to watch the one
who created you then Islam is right for
you we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you I cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you are not yet
Muslim and you're tuning in to see what
these Muslims are talking about and you
like a free copy of the Quran go and
visit thedenshow.com we'll take care of
the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum